hi everybody my name is karen strauss
and i'm a principal research manager at
microsoft
and today i'm going to talk about
storing digital data in dna
and computing with molecules
this is a collaboration between
microsoft and university of washington
and together we created the molecular
information systems lab
to study what biology and chemistry can
do for
computer science and for information
technology
so let's start with with a problem
storage capacity
is growing a lot slower than our ability
to generate
data so what i'm showing here in the
these plots
on the left hand side i'm showing a
study by idc
showing the speed at which the digital
universe has been growing
and the bottom curve is how fast
devices to store the information has
been growing so as you can see there
over the years the gap has been
increasing
and we think that's a problem it's not
like we need to store
all the data we generate but we actually
want to store a portion of it
and the reason the gap is concerning is
what i'm showing here on the right hand
side
where you're seeing the evolution over
time of the portion
of the data we'll be able to store out
of all the data we generate
if we simply follow this trend so we
think that
to put a dent on this problem we need to
change
the approach so let me illustrate uh
what i mean with changing the approach
so here i'm showing
two icons of the computing era and um
so on the left hand side i have more and
many of you have heard if not all of you
have heard of moore's law so moore's law
essentially states that
the number of transistors doubles every
so often
and so the whole computing industry
has been relying on increasing the
number of devices on a chip and doing
more
with that just shrinking them and doing
more with new devices because they have
more transistors they can do more
to contrast this approach with the
molecular approach which is
is what i'm talking about um is uh
an example here is feynman so in one of
his famous lectures
feynman essentially advocated that if we
can arrange the item
atoms in whatever way we want um
then the um we should be able to store
and compute
with uh directly with uh atoms and
molecules
and in fact in in this lecture he even
used dna as an example of information
storage
with molecules so he pointed out that
dna molecules
they use about 50 atoms to to store
about one bit of information
he stopped short of really suggesting
that we use that
in in the industry in the computing
industry
but that idea didn't didn't take very
long to surface and in fact a few years
later
it was observed that you could also if
you could manipulate how to make
dna molecules you could store digital
information in dna
all right so let's see what dna data
storage
is if you think of dna we learn about
dna as the double helix
each side of that double helix is a
sequence of
four types of bases a c g and t
and so uh dna and our genome is
essentially
a combination of these four uh bases in
different sequences
if we want to store bits in dna all we
have to do
is take a sequence of bits and convert
that into a sequence of bases of dna
bases
so here i'm showing a simple mapping
where we're taking every two bits
and converting that into a different
base so 0 0 corresponds to a
0 1 2 c and so forth and so on
the mapping that we use in reality is
actually more sophisticated than that
but this is more to illustrate the point
here that we can translate
bits to bases and then now we have the
technology
to produce these molecules in arbitrary
sequences and so
the technology can produce
molecules with arbitrary sequences that
we determine
from 150 to 200 bases and we store
the information we fabricate these
molecules of dna
with the arbitrary sequences now so this
is synthetic dna so to be very clear
there's no organisms no life it's just
the dna
used as a medium like tape is used to
store information
uh so why would we want to use dna to
store digital information
the first the first argument for it
is density so here what i'm showing is a
test tube
the pink smear you see in the bottom of
that test tube and you can compare the
size of that to the pencil that's next
to it
uh is equivalent dna to store about 10
terabytes of data which is what
can be stored in hard drives today right
so
quite denser than than hard drives
and what this translates when we talk
about data centers
is that the information stored in a
building like this
which to they can hold about house about
one exabyte of information
if scaled to the size of dna can
be about that size so it is a scaled
size it's essentially a pixel in mine's
line
but really in reality that one that one
exabyte of data
fits in the palm of your hand so it's
about a cubic inch
of volume that can fit one exabyte of
information stored in dna
so density is uh quite important and and
we think that
it will be pretty important for uh
storing information long term so
archival storage
next property which is also important
for archival storage
is how long the data lasts
when stored in a particular media and so
dna can store thousands of years in fact
in nature there's demonstrations of dna
keeping
the information for hundreds of
thousands of years
but scientists have also developed ways
to encapsulate the dna to create
conditions similar to conditions uh
that happen in nature that will conserve
preserve the dna for a long time and
in fact these conditions are not that
difficult to keep and in fact the sheer
density
of dna as a medium also helps
with that task so it's it's very easy to
keep those conditions for
a small volume so that begs a comparison
with other commercial storage media
here i'm showing a set of different
commercial media
and comparing that with dna the plot is
comparing density and then there's
durability
uh compared below
for density what you're seeing there is
the
the bottom part is where those
technologies
were when we when we created this plot a
couple years ago
and then the next part of those bars are
where we expect the technology to get to
and for dna what you're seeing um the
top of the bar there
is where we expect uh the limit
of uh the density for dna to be but
obviously
that's the theoretical limit and if
we're building a system
with dna just like the other uh the
other type of media
uh there's an overhead associated with
uh creating a system and so
even when we discount that overhead we
still get a few orders of magnitude
improvement
compared to the densest existing
technology which today's tip
another property of dna is that now that
we know how to read dna
we'll always be able to to read it
so we'll always have technology to read
the dna
and the medium itself doesn't change
it's just the dna
but the readers can improve and they can
improve
independently of the medium itself which
is
not really the case for for other types
of commercial media
and finally something we've
found out recently by doing a study on
on sustainability
is that dna promises to to be
better also from from a sustainability
perspective so
for metrics that we looked at to store
one terabyte of information for a year
it looks like the greenhouse gas
emissions
the energy consumption and the water
consumption will be
lower for dna so we still need to build
the system to validate these numbers but
the numbers
look pretty promising as well all right
so
here if we if we're going to build a dna
data storage system
how what does that look and uh so here
is uh what it looks like so the first
transition
encoding from bits into basis so this
happens in the electronic domain so
we're essentially using a computer to
translate
bits into sequences of bases
uh to be manufactured and then we go to
the manufacturing process
once we have the molecules and the data
is uh safely
stored in the molecules we will preserve
the information that's in the dna
and and that the information or the
molecules will be encapsulated
and put away and then when when it's
time to read the information again
we'll retrieve the molecules we want to
reach that's the random axis
we'll sequence them and then we'll
decode the information recovering the
bits
what we've done so far uh is to store
the information about one gigabit of
information we've stored and
recovered this information and what we
wanted to make a point about is that
we encoded different types of media and
we did that because we wanted to make
the points that if you can encode that
into
into bits you can encode them into dna
as well
and so we've encoded books from the
gutenberg
from project gutenberg so the 100 top
books in project gutenberg
we've encoded the universal declaration
of human rights
we've encoded the high definition ok
go video in fact i would highly
recommend that that video
uh we've encoded databases we've encoded
archival quality music
from the montreal jazz festival and so
forth and so on
and um this uh one gigabyte may not
sound
like a a big deal when it comes to
information storage but
from a biotech uh perspective that's
that's actually quite a big deal and
this has
landed us on the cover of
nature biotechnology that that paper um
we in that paper we describe our
experiences encoding
uh 200 megabytes of information in dna
and um and after that we've encoded 800
megabytes more
but as far as we know this is the most
data
ever stored in dna published in a peer
review
publication so looking at the evolution
of dna here
what i'm showing is how much it's been
growing how the capacity
stored in dna has been growing over time
so what you're seeing on the y-axis
on the x-axis is ears and on the y-axis
is the amount of information that has
been stored and note that the
the x y axis here is um is a logarithmic
and so that that essentially means that
capacity has been growing
exponentially over the years and i hope
it will continue to do so
so now what i thought i'd do is walk you
through
uh this pipeline in more detail so let's
see how how exactly we do
this process of storing digital data in
dna and recovery
recovering it
first step is the encoding so this video
that we encoded is about 44 megabytes of
information
but as i mentioned to you earlier
it's easy to fabricate molecules of dna
that's a that are about 150 to 230
um bases long and that means that we can
store about
um 15 to 30 bytes in each of the
molecules each of the sequences
and so the first step is really taking
this
taking this file and chopping it up into
smaller pieces
pieces that will fit into molecules of
dna
next we add the sequence number so that
we can find them when it's time to
recover the information and reorder them
in the original sequence that the file
encoded we add some redundant
information and that's for error
correction purposes on the way
out on the way the decoding path
we'll translate then those sequences
into
uh from bits into into bases
we'll add a tag and think of this as a
file id
or as a some object id
of some sort so that all the molecules
that are part of the same file or the
same data object
are tagged with the same id and so we
know that they belong to that file and
we can
recover that file as a unit all right so
the next step now we know the sequences
that we want to store in dna
so the next step is really to
manufacture the molecules and
that process is called dna synthesis
and um essentially it's a a number of
different
chemical steps uh where different
reagents are brought in
that are used to build the dna or to
grow the dna base by base
and the process is very much like you
know
the way to visualize it is grass growing
from
uh from the ground up so bases are added
one by one
in that particular blade of of grass
obviously we don't grow a single blade
at a time there's process called array
synthesis
that grows different sequences in
parallel
so once the molecules are grown they're
removed
from that surface where the they grew
and they are encapsulated and this
is so that the dna is preserved over a
long period of time
and then the dna is organized so it's
not a mountain of dna
all together it's organized into a
library and
which is what i'm showing here is a dna
library much
like a library of tape that's used to
store digital information
is organized so it's organized spatially
and if you need a particular piece of
data you know
in which location to find it
so that library is stored it's preserved
and it's stored
under the right conditions for the dna
to be stable
and when it's time to read the
information
we'll retrieve the molecules from from
the library
and then it's time to sequence it
or read the information in the molecule
so sequencing
there's multiple ways of sequencing dna
the most used today is an optical
method where uh whenever you want to
read the dna you're
essentially making a copy of it and so a
base will be added that's complementary
to the base in the dna so remember how i
said
uh dnas of double helix and each side of
the double helix has
a sequence of bases well
if on one side of the double helix you
have an a on the other side you have a t
if on one side you have a c on the other
side you have a g
and so they're they're matched together
so that from an information storage
perspective they're redundant
but we can actually leverage this
process to read the information in the
dna so here in this
example here what just happened
let me replay that is that a t
that was flown in into the flow cell
which is where the dna that's being read
sits in in this machine um a t
with a fluorescent uh group that's
that's essentially a chemical that
fluoresces
attached to this molecule here so we
know that
t is normally attached to a's and
therefore
the um this green light that we're
seeing coming from that location
corresponds to an a and likewise uh we
can repeat
the uh we can repeat this process so
remove that
fluorescent group and attach the next
base in this case it's a g
with a yellowish um fluorophore
and so we're seeing a different uh
different base
uh identified there uh and that that's
complementary to the c
so we know there's a c in that position
and so forth and so on
so what this machine generates is
essentially
a number of different sequences of the
molecules that it thinks is observed
now this is all inferred by the the
optical properties and so it there are a
few errors that accumulate because of
the process itself
here's another method this is called
nanopore
reading or nanopore sequencing
technology and
this device is essentially a handheld
device
and it the the way it reads the dna is
electronic
so the dna is forced through this
nanopore so it's a nanoscale
pore the dna is forced through
that pore and as it goes through it
disturbs the ionic current of
the liquid that's that's going through
the pore and by
depending on which bases are going
through that pore
it generates a different electrical
signal that that can be inferred
uh to uh the original molecule that
that's probably
uh going uh going through that nanopore
and so it
again the sequencing technology
generates a bunch of
what's called reads and those are uh
noisy representations of the molecules
observed by the
uh by the sequencer so now we have a
bunch of reads
um and those are sequences and we need
to translate back into
the the bits so let's see how this is
done
the decoding process starts by
clustering
the reads and so what we're doing is
essentially finding reads that are
likely to have come from the same
location in the original file and then
for each of these clusters
we'll do majority voting and to
determine what's the most likely
sequence that came from that position
the next step is to take these majority
voted sequences
and translate them back into bits
just by the the mapping that we had used
in the beginning
and then reordering them based on their
sequence number
and uh even though most of the the bits
we've stored
uh come back and and we can recover them
some of them
actually uh don't and so they're missing
molecules and
and the information in them is gone and
so
uh but we've um if you remember in the
beginning and the encoding
part we actually added some redundancy
and so we can use that redundancy now
to recover the original data so this
obviously there's quite a bit of
computer science and
coding theory that goes into creating
these codes
but luckily we have it microsoft
research a great team
of people working on this so once we
have these
sequences of bits we can reorder them
and reassemble the original file
so this is how in a nutshell we store
um the the information in dna and then
are able
to recover it so this is again the
pipeline that
we just talked about and essentially
the last thing i wanted to point out
about it is that there's
there's parts of it that are you know in
the electronic domain it's parts of it
that are in the molecular domain and
then we recover
the information uh to the electronic
domain so essentially we have an
electronic
molecular uh hybrid system here
and we're using the different uh
different technologies for what they do
best
ultimately what we'd like to get to is
is a system like this
right it's a system that can write store
and read
uh information to and from uh
dna that we can place in a data center
then wrap a
service around it and offer for example
an archival storage service to your
customers
so once we achieved something like this
the next question is can can we do any
kind of computation directly into
molecules so that we don't need to read
the information back so that we can
process so can we process the
information
at the molecular level and it turns out
that certain kinds of computations can
be done
directly in the molecule so let me tell
you a little bit about that
so here's the assumption we we've stored
a bunch of
information in dna and we have certain
operations that need to be done
for example over all of those pieces of
information right so for example search
search is a good example of that um if
we
want to search a particular database we
may have to look at
all the all the elements in the database
to to get
something where we're looking for right
so we target these kinds of algorithms
uh where parallelism can actually be
quite helpful and also we think that uh
using molecules and and those properties
of dna of binding
a binding just to t and c binding to g
to do energy efficient computation
especially when it comes to search
so let me show you what property of dna
that we're
exploring so here what i'm showing is uh
different molecules of dna
the top one is the normal double helix
that we think about where
uh a's uh match uh t's and and c's match
g's uh exactly right and
what keeps that molecule together are
the attraction forces between those
pairs of bases so a's are attracting t's
and and c
is attracting g's right and so
that that force is is quite strong and
it keeps the molecule
together right as a unit now that
doesn't mean that if there's a
one mismatch the molecule will fall
apart right
um so if there's a good partial match
which is what i'm showing here on the
on the bottom left the molecule will
still
you know stick together it may not stick
as strongly as before but it
but the there's still some attraction
between the two sides of the bow helix
and then
even poor partial matches sometimes uh
may still you know there may still uh be
some attraction so let me show you how
we would
use that for search
so this is how we use dna for search
on the left hand side let's say there is
a database here for illustration
purposes
there are three uh three items in the
database and each of the items is
represented by three molecules so we
have three copies of the same molecule
of the same sequence
representing each item and in the middle
what we have is a query
and that query is connected to a
magnetic nanoparticle
and so we can physically actuate over
that magnetic
nanoparticle by using a magnet
so once uh all of these molecules are
mixed what we expect to see is the
following
if there's a perfect match we're going
to see very strong attraction
between the query and a database item
and so all the molecules all the copies
of that particular item
are going to come together with the
query and form this very strong double
helix
structure if there is a not so perfect
match uh just a good match
molecules are still going to come
together but probably fewer of them will
come together because the forces are
are not as strong and then if there are
poor partial matches
you know maybe fewer pairs will form
and um and then we can use this property
to
really search a database so how do we do
that
so imagine we have a database of images
and here i'm showing
these four images as examples
by using just regular machine learning
techniques we can extract
a feature vector from each of these
images that sort of describes that
that image and then instead of storing
or
further processing those feature vectors
we will actually
train a neural network to translate
these feature vectors into sequences of
dna
such that if images are similar they are
likely to have
similar sequences of dna representing
them
in that database and then when we have a
query
like this so this is again a binocular
we have a binocular here in the database
as well
uh we'll do feature extraction over that
new query
over it over that image extract a
feature vector and run it through the
same
uh the same neurometric now
um these sequences representing the two
binoculars are similar but if we
want them to stick together what we need
to do is essentially invert
and rev what's called reverse complement
uh
the query or the sequence representing
that query
so that um essentially every c becomes a
g
every t becomes an a and so that
molecule is the molecule that's likely
to
stick to the image we're looking for
when it's mixed into
the database of images and then we can
use a magnetic
uh or a magnet to pull it because the
query is attached to a magnetic
nanoparticle
so that's how we're doing search in dna
we've had quite a bit of success in um
recovering images that are that are
similar and
we have uh one uh dna 24
uh paper on that uh and uh
one more um under submission right now
so hopefully we'll
you'll see you know more news about this
uh soon
all right so uh i've talked quite a bit
about this
um in the um abstract but one
one uh very common way to doing all
these experiments and showing
demonstrating the system and
understanding the behavior of dna
is what you're seeing this picture here
is essentially by hand so
synthesis and and sequencing today are
actually
you know the commercial senses and
sequencing are actually
automated fully automated but what
happens in between
still relies on manual steps like this
one
so we wanted to
understand what it took to really build
a system end-to-end the fully automated
system for dna storage
our point uh was not really to build
a large-scale system of any sort we we
wanted to demonstrate that it was
possible to do the entire process
using uh just automation without any
human intervention
but again the point of this was not
scaling
up was was really proving
automation and so we built this
contraption here
and what i'm showing here is essentially
a dna data storage system
fully automated dna data storage system
on the left hand side what you're seeing
is a bunch of bottles
those are the bottles and the reagents
needed to make dna
and even you know those four smaller
bottles you see
in the back are the the four different
uh bases uh those are
the you know just solutions that carried
those bases
uh now in the middle what you're seeing
is essentially the
storage and preparation unit and then on
the right hand side
uh you're seeing the sequencing portion
of the system
and what you're seeing there uh is
uh the nano port device that i was
talking about earlier so we integrated
the nano port device with the the rest
of the system here
um so this is um a detail of
the the actual place where we're storing
the dna it's in the bottom of this
this tube here so
we we use this contraption to write the
word hello
in dna and then we were able to fully uh
recover that without any hands-on
effort so this this was fully automated
all right but um you know that that
library that i showed
here can essentially store one one
particular pool of dna
if we want a a a bigger library then we
need to think about how to do that
um so this elaborate tape and we kept
thinking what's the equivalent of that
for dna data storage and
essentially this is what we came up with
so this is a device
based on digital microfluidics so let me
tell you a little more about that
the effect that we're exploring
exploiting here is called electro
wetting
so essentially we can sandwich droplets
of fluid
carrying dna or carrying other reagents
between
a computer board a pcb which is the
um the purple board that that you're
seeing there or the
the green board in the the next uh the
text image
and um so the droplet is sandwiched
between the board and a sheet of
conductive and depending on where we
applied voltages
across the the sheet and the board
uh we're going to deform the the
droplets so that
we can operate over them so we can move
them uh
we can split them we can merge them and
so forth and so on and that allows us to
uh both use it as a library um to
you know park different droplets of
fluid on
uh the the the glass plate and and store
you know just dry the molecules and
store them there uh but also use the
platform to prepare the molecules to
uh read the dna process uh to process
the dna
um we've also uh wanted to make it close
loop so we added a camera this is what
you're seeing in the middle
so a board with a a a green droplet
there and the camera is the the blue
base uh is on the blue base and
it's with that uh circuit that's
that's hanging upside down there uh on
the top
and um essentially we use the the camera
to
observe the movement of the droplet
around the
the platform and uh by using the camera
we can also identify the droplets and
and track them as they're operated over
so
on the right hand side here what you're
seeing is a video
that is tracking these these droplets
and so
you know the first few frames showed
that the the different droplets being
identified with an id and then when they
merged they have a new id and so we can
track
where the droplets are going and what
they're being mixed with
um so obviously you know that that's the
hardware but it also requires a little
bit of
programming to be useful so when we
started we had the hardware and
a pretty simple assembly code that
allowed us to activate
the different electrodes to move the
fluids around
but it felt like there was an
opportunity here to again apply computer
science
to the system and so
again in collaboration with the
university of washington we developed a
publ which is essentially a runtime
that allows a composition of different
functions
to manipulate droplets on the board so
for example we can implement
a process called pcr which is the
process of copying the molecules and
amplifying
the information so just copying the
information and
this essentially uh
can be implemented uh with the language
on top of this this platform here
so um right now we're essentially
building this stack
with dna data storage in mind but
hopefully in the future
we'll see uh adoption of it for uh
high throughput experiments for medical
diagnostics and so forth and so on
this is essentially one uh particular
example of automation
that connects the molecular domain and
the electronic domain so
in this talk we've seen uh the the
end-to-end system we've seen
uh synthesis and sequencing and we've
seen
the purple drop technology uh but the
bigger point i wanted to make is that i
think we're going to see
more of these these systems where
there's an interface between the
molecular domain
and the electronic domain and just like
you know today we see cpus being
accelerated by
gpus and fpgas i think that uh
tomorrow we're going to see different
types of systems
so quantum systems as an example but
also biomolecules as
hopefully i've shown you uh during the
uh during the presentation today that we
can use uh biomolecules both
to store information and to compute
certain types of
computations so to perform certain types
of
computations using molecules
but overall i think the the the thing we
need to think about is what
what technology fits a particular
problem better and
and really i think the future is a
variety of these technologies operating
together
so with that i wanted to conclude by
saying
this is the work of a a large team of
people so this is not
uh just me and luis says in my peer at
university of washington but really
a team of very talented and super
motivated researchers uh it's a very
diverse team
um you know lots of different
backgrounds all the way from coding
theory
to molecular biology and we
are uh super happy and super excited to
to work on on this topic so with that
we're going to transition into a live q
a session
so if you'd like to participate in that
please stay tuned
hi everyone thanks for attending the dna
data storage and computation
webinar and live q a i'm karen strauss a
principal research manager here at
microsoft
and over the next 15 minutes or so we're
going to be
answering top questions submitted by the
audience during the webinar
so let's get started our first question
relates to
what type of dna we use for data storage
so one thing i want to emphasize and
clarify is that we're not
using biological dna we're using
synthetic dna
this means that there's no organisms
no life related to the dna that we're
using it's really
the dna that's manufactured by a
chemical process
so it's the same material but there are
no cells no organisms
and no life associated to the dna that
we're using for data storage
second question is is there a reason why
we wouldn't use dna
for encoding data and relatedly
a different question asked apart from
dna
has there been any interest in other
types of synthetic molecules for data
storage or computation
and could we design our own dna-like
molecule with say
16 bases instead of 4. okay so let's
start with the rna question
you could use the same process to
use rna for data storage it turns out
rna is is a single stranded so it's only
one side
uh typically of that double helix and so
it's not as stable as dna
and then if we wanted to use other types
of molecules yes um
you could use other types of synthetic
molecules and it turns out there is
research in this area um
what's um there are two reasons why we
uh don't see that these
synthetic molecules were in in use in
widespread use today
and this is because um you know there
are more tools to manipulate dna so
the tools to synthesize or to write the
dna
to manipulate or copy the dna and to
read the dna are more widespread they're
more available and so it's easier
as a starting point to use dna it
doesn't mean that we'll never use other
types of synthetic molecules for data
storage and computation
but this is what's uh most easily uh
available today so that that's with
where we start
could we design our own dna-like
molecule with more bases so instead of
having the a t c
and g natural basis could we have it
with
different uh different bases that that
would
essentially enrich our vocabulary of
symbols and therefore
would make us able to store more bits
per base would we would be able to map
more bits per
per base of dna and it turns out that
there are synthetic
uh bases of dna that look different that
are not the atc
and g however
the thing to to keep in mind is that
if we have four bases as i showed in the
beginning of the presentation we can
encode
four different combinations of two bits
each
if we have if we double the number of
bases for example
we uh we had eight different
bases a t c and g and then our
rs and xy for example we'd be able to
encode you know there's
eight different bases to choose from
however those eight different bases
means that we can encode
three bits because uh those would cover
the
all the eight combinations of three bits
all the way from zero
zero zero zero zero one and etc to
one one zero one one one and so there's
eight combinations there of bits
therefore we can
encode three bits so with four
bases we can encode two bits with eight
bases we can encode three bits
with 16 bases we can encode four bits
and so every time we want to encode an
extra bit we need to double the number
of bases
and it turns out that designing these
artificial synthetic bases
is a non-trivial task so there there
is a possibility of using more bases but
it may not pay off as much as
the work it takes to create some more of
those
all right next question is are there
any limitations to the
sequences of synthetic dna in other
words are there any sequences that
cannot
be created cannot be synthesized
it turns out that some sequences are
harder than others
um not only to synthesize or write
but also to copy and to be read and
luckily when we encode bits into
dna we can choose
how to do that encoding and we can
choose to avoid
some of these sequences and by avoiding
these sequences we make it easier
for ourselves to write the dna
manipulate the dna and read the dna
all right uh next question was does the
dna medium
cause natural errors analogous to
hardware errors in electronics
yes there are errors throughout the
process so
both in writing manipulating the dna and
as the dna ages certain errors are
introduced
and then in reading the dna
uh it turns out that just like other
hardware errors there are mechanisms for
error correction
and so this is this is what we do we use
mathematical codes
to avoid these errors uh
and by avoid i mean uh we encode
redundant information but in a
mathematical way that allows us to
encode not
that much more information together with
the original information we want to
store and when it's time to
to recover the data we can use that
redundancy that we inserted
in the beginning of the process to
recover the bits
despite errors in the molecules in the
bases in the reading the writing
of those dna molecules so we can recover
the information
because we're using coding theory we're
using mathematical
concepts to uh to be able to recover
that from
not that much more additional data
next question is is it possible to
replicate data
in synthetic dna yes it's possible
all we need to do is to copy the
molecules and it turns out
there's a process called pcr or
polymerase chain reaction
that precisely copies dna so we can make
many copies in fact many copies in
parallel
and replicate the data in that way and
so once the copies are made we can just
divide
that material into two and then we have
two copies or more
copies right all right
uh next question is also about copying
so if the
data is needed to be copied how's the
integrity of the information preserved
in in other words
how would we prevent quote unquote
generic
drift in the information um
so generic uh excuse me genetic drift
in the information so this is
referring to changes in the basis so if
you have an original
sequence of dna let's see let's say it's
a ac tng
that sequence and instead
in copying you know there's an error and
the copied uh sequences a c c
g um so we we had a substitution there
and again the those uh smart
mathematical models that i was talking
about uh mathematical
techniques uh coming from coding theory
help us recover the information bit by
bit despite
neither of these processes neither the
the writing
the copying or the reading process uh
being
exactly precise uh they do insert errors
and we can correct
and recover the bits despite the errors
in the
the molecules and the the processes to
read and write
and copy all right so
next question was how well does dna
store
in archival format so does it need to be
dehydrated or frozen
or kept in certain environmental
conditions
so the best conditions to maintain dna
are cool
dark and away from uh
from moisture from from water away from
oxygen
so one of the
the methods to store the dna is to
freeze it at very low temperatures
another method is to dehydrate it
sometimes seal it with some kind of
inert gas
so there are multiple ways to maintain
the dna
it's all a function of how long we
want to preserve the dna and
how you know other properties that we
may want perhaps we don't want to keep
it super cold
and but but we have the ability to seal
the dna
and some some kind of sealed chamber
with inert gases
that that would be a their ways to
encapsulate the dna
with silicon dioxide
so it's kind of like a synthetic bone
that involves the dna and really
protects it from from degradation
and keeping it away from from light as
well is
something that's that's recommended so
there's there's a number of
different conditions and combinations of
conditions that can be used to preserve
the dna
and make it last for a longer amount of
time which essentially prefer
preserves the data that's encoded in the
dna
all right so next question is if if uh
dna storage uh space gets contaminated
uh meaning there's some uh biological
dna perhaps that's in
is introduced in the mix is there a way
to to fix the data and still
recover the data um uh where that
contamination happened
so it turns out that when we create
sequences of dna for data storage they
look very different from
biological sequences of dna
and moreover the copying process allows
us to specifically copy
the the different molecules that were
used for
that data storage and so
it turns out that we can that we can
recover only the molecules that were
used for data storage
and not necessarily for um you know not
necessarily the biological one so we can
separate
them by uh looking at the structure of
the molecule and taking advantage of
that
all right um this is a question about
the digital microfluidics platform
that i showed um in one of those lines
where
where we showed the the droplets moving
right so
the question is what kind of time scales
do these droplets
move on so and and then a related
question was how fast
it can mix and then what sort of dna
quantities
so the platform you saw moves droplets
that are about two
uh to tens of uh microliters
of um dna solution right so that's dna
in water or some kind of buffered
solution so water and different thoughts
um and and that's those are the
quantities that are moved
by that particular platform that i was
uh
showing in in the video you can move
smaller
droplets as well with a different
different sorts of
digital microfluidics platforms
time scale so in the platform i showed
droplets can move
millimeters per second is sort of a
reasonable unit to
to think about those um so
uh it turns out that it's actually quite
quick when you when you see you know the
demo
um i don't know how easy it was to see
in the video
uh in the webinar but um but that's
that's a real time we did not accelerate
um the uh the speed of the droplet so
that's real time
uh speed next question
from your results um would dna data
storage be more suitable for code
storage
hot storage or both and how far a
different question is how far
are we from having this technology and
laptops and mobile phones
so i can comment i think on where
i think we're going to see dna data
storage first i think we're going to see
it
for code storage in data centers
and and this is uh because uh
you know that's where the technology is
right now it
a little while to get to the data so
it's not instant like what we're used to
with hard drives
um i expect that it will uh become
faster and faster to access data
in uh dna um and
but but i think it's it's pretty clear
that we're starting uh with uh code
storage at this point
and then a question about how how far
uh are we from having technology and
laptops and mobile phones
um again we're probably gonna see dna
data storage in data centers before
we see it in laptops and mobile phones
and this is
because it's easier to create the
conditions the conditions are
more controlled in a data center and so
it's easier to
to place such a new device in a data
center environment rather than a laptop
or a mobile phone
so the jury is still out on when we're
going to see
laptops and mobile phones have the
technology
but um uh you know it seems like it will
get there someday
all right different question assuming uh
we're successful uh in
enabling dna data storage uh what
computation
ever sees being electronic so will we
still
have electronic computers or or not and
i think we will um there are there are
things that dna is good for
there are things that electronics are is
good for
and it's really the combination of
electronics
molecules potentially quantum computing
and so forth and so on
that that's that's going to be you know
platforms of
of the future are are going to include i
think they're going to include all those
components and this is not very
different from platforms today so we
have
uh cpus but we also have gpus we have
fpgas and other
other types of electronics and different
technologies in our systems
and they do different things um and we
use
um the best technology for the best desk
um so we'll see combinations of
of these technologies in the future as
well
all right it looks like we have time for
one more question today
um so uh here's the last question
if someone wanted to get involved with
this kind of research
what kind of background education
training would they need to possess
okay so to answer that question i think
the the best is to
say what kinds of competencies we cover
within our team here at microsoft it's
actually a pretty
uh broad team even more with the
collaboration
uh with university of washington so um
you know it's it's quite
broad and there's a variety of different
backgrounds education and training
uh people can have and and work on the
project so this is goes all the way from
coding theory which is a part of
theoretical computer science
to algorithms to background in
computer architecture electrical and
mechanical engineering
molecular biology biochemistry and so
forth and so on so
there's quite a a wide array of
different disciplines to to study
i think it's fair to say that nobody in
our team is specialist on
all of those areas but really
one cool thing about the project is that
we we are all coming together
um creating the same language and and
being able to communicate
across the different disciplines to
really you know create a system that
strides all of these disciplines
and and essentially delivers on
this promise of dna data storage and
computation
so with that i'd like to thank you all
for
attending today we really appreciate
your participation and your
interest in in the subject if you're
interested to to learn more
we have listed some great resources in
the
resource list and that's to the right of
your screen
the list includes you know papers we've
written on
dna data storage on dna computation
and even one uh that mixes dna data
storage and art
so that's that's uh what you're gonna
find in the resources list
uh we'd like look forward to seeing how
you
you build on this research and evolve
dna data storage
so that's it for today have a great day
bye bye